Presidency changed in March that was the
old system and then we revised the
Constitution so that now we're new
presents are installed in January it
really is a very short period of time
for a new team coming in Christopher
Hitchins Washington Post on and
transition article over the weekend said
Clinton's every word scrutinized
yielding varied interpretations um what
if obviously thunderously tedious
headline I don't know how they dream
them up how could it be otherwise I mean
how could do have you know headline that
said nobody reads what the president
says never one agrees on every word of
it how about the very real boy is there
and are you drawing an assessment out of
watching what's been happening a little
right so far I've been just amazed to
find that um people can look at a guest
list at a party for Pamela Harriman
given by Pamela Harriman and say this is
the regime of change I mean it takes
real effort to do this the Washington
Post is doing its best to make
everything look exciting I am noting
with an insider or an access journalist
at all the look at the guest list for
Pamela Harmons party and recognize every
single name in every single face as a
familiar political figure I just wish
people wouldn't keep talking about
change change changes that there's
nothing more out-of-date than the people
who are up to the minute okay let me
come back to another element that I
think what is happening here Susan in in
many ways Bill Clinton is getting off to
a favorable start there's a poll that
over the weekend it shows that
two-thirds of the country likes the what
he's doing in transition what I think
we're learning Bill Clinton is learning
out of this transition is it's one thing
to be a governor of Arkansas and other
thing to be a candidate and quite a
different thing to be president-elect in
the sense that I think Bill Clinton's a
talker
he likes to talk his way through
questions and as he does that he you
know he comes down on one side of the
other the questionable but his emphasis
changes and nobody paid much attention
to those two those those shifts in is in
his emphasis as he was a governor or
candidate now that he's president elect
every time he shifts tax just a little
bit people think that's a change in what
he's saying and he's the one negative
it's creeping into the transition is
whether he's waffling too much whether
he's shifting his position too much
whether he seems to cave or
under pressure from Congress or from the
president or whatever it may be so there
are a number of issues last week that
the press was raising questions is he
bending in the wind too much is it this
is the very thing of course that George
Bush used him of during the campaign
it's one thing I Keys find a little
tricky as he maneuvers through this
transition good morning from Washington
thanks for being with us this morning
our Monday morning program we invite two
journalists to our table and let me tell
you a little bit more about our format
this morning for the first half hour of
our 90-minute program these two
gentlemen at our desk here at c-span
will be taking us several issues that
are in the news right now and discussing
and debating them a bit at the half hour
mark we open up our telephone lines and
invite you to participate well put our
c-span phone numbers on the bottom of
the screen so as your questions or your
comments come to mind about the this
week's news stories you are most welcome
to dial in for our discussion portion of
the program
those numbers 2 0 to 6 to 8 to 5 to 5 if
you live in the Eastern or central time
zones to 0 to 7 8 3 to 7 to 7 if you
live in the mountain or Pacific time
zones and again we go to the phones in
about 25 minutes we tell you a bit about
our guest this morning Christopher
Hitchens is with us he is a Washington
writer whose columns appear in Vanity
Fair and in the nation how long have you
been in Washington now 10 years the
summer Thank You mr. veteran what tell
me a bit about what kinds of things
interest you as you look about your
subject matter well the con that I wrote
Vanity Fair that I've just started to
write it's called to cultural elite
which is a term that I hope will be one
of the few that survives the outgoing
administration why because I think it's
not a good term I think it's a good term
for people who have a Polymathic general
interest in everything and aren't
particularly dogmatic or narrow-minded
and I think prefers great magazine for
that because I think it's it's the it's
probably the best general readership
magazine in the business why should I
say probably I should be ingratiating
myself more with my new employers anyway
it means that I can write I can claim to
be interested in everything and in
nothing else which is the definition I
was heard of a polymath which will do
for me the definition you once out of a
what I heard of a polymer someone who's
interested in everything and enough
hils david gergen is editor-at-large of
US News and World Report join us Sue's
in 1984 and became an editor with
publication in 1984 came editor in 1985
left the editorship in 88 to write and
comment more broadly on national and
international affairs see him regularly
on some of the Washington talk programs
including macneil/lehrer Newshour and a
frequent commentator on National Public
Radio's All Things Considered welcome
thank you nice to have you with us let
me go into this article a little bit
more in-depth that I mentioned from The
Washington Post it was written by Ruth
Marcus and in it she writes if the
genius of the Clinton campaign was its
discipline focused on the message the
economy stupid the Clinton transition
stumbled slightly out of the gate
although it harnessed masterfully the
new prestige of the president-elect with
Clinton symbolic reaching out to common
people during his walk on Georgia Avenue
it has also endured a torrent of stories
about such quote off message and quote
matters as homosexuals in the military
and the role of Hillary Clinton David
Gordon start you well you know the
president-elect starts with the fact
that there's a news vacuum and there are
2000 people pulling over the ground
taking pictures and capturing every word
and chasing his cat around trying to get
you know 5 to 10 25 photographers a case
chasing a cat you know that there's a
there's very little going on the cat
isn't even up a tree that's right it was
flushed out I think with cat nap out of
out of out of the mansion grounds or
something
the and I got the Clintons were not
terribly happy about the invasion of
privacy but not but nonetheless what
that means is of course isn't that every
time he opens mouth about anything it
becomes a matter of intense interest on
the part of the president and early
press conference for example he was
asked about homosexuals in the military
something he talked about in the
campaign it came right around Veterans
Day bang it became a story it was a big
story became of controversy again a
general powell and others have voiced
discontent with with the notion he's
every time he meets with the members of
congress or other things there are other
there all sorts of special interests
going after him now trying to say you
got to fulfil this pledge you got to
make that pledge at the top of the list
so i think he has lost a little bit of
the focus on the economy which is after
all the number one issue in the
when what she was elected are those two
stories mentioned by Ruth Marcus
gays-in-the-military and Hillary Clinton
legitimate stories
I think legitimate yes will there's
something farcical I think about the the
gays in the military business if if
there wasn't a ban on gays in the
military already who would be arguing
that the rule to be one is I think the
way to think about it
only one other NATO country Great
Britain has such about and the other
simply avoid the question they mean why
let it come up everybody knows that one
in every let's say twelve or so men is
going to be gay and most people just
know that there's nothing you can do
about that and growing up about it I
would like to hear people make the case
for imposing a ban if there wasn't one
as it is it's a it's a terrible
non-issue we wish to start a presidency
I think the first lady business much
more important honestly I mean because
you can derive certain clues from it and
I thought that got off to a bad start
with them complaining about invasion of
privacy because of pictures of the damn
cat socks we I you had to sit through
the Clintons discussing their marriage
on television when I didn't want to hear
anything about it
and though they've had to be told much
more about Chelsea than I ever wanted to
know I mean they've been invading my
privacy forcing me to know things about
everything from their therapy to their
daughter now this it that they should
start complaining about the cat suggests
that they're beginning to get sort of to
bigger sense of themselves I think David
Grogan this is your column in US News
where you write about the question of
gays in the military in the headline the
commander's first minefield and what
were your thoughts on this column well I
have some disagreement Christopher about
the importance of the issues of the
military it's it's been a this has been
a 48 year old band and it there it there
is a deep-seated feeling within the
military and one just has to go out and
talk to folks who serve about the
disruption that would bring to bring
gays into the military there's a sense
that it would lower morale there talks
about resignation there there are some
legitimate concerns that I think have to
be addressed about what the rules ought
to be at the same time
mr. Quentin campaigned on this issue it
was out there he got elected he is the
commander in chief this is a civilian
run military and it seems to me having
extended himself in the way he has he
cannot back down now for him to cave in
on this issue when he's been so plain
spoken about it in the past I think
would destroy his presidency I think we
lose control of his presidency so I
think he has to move forward I think he
has to do it with with sensitivity I
think he has to do it with an
understanding that there are legitimate
concerns that have to be addressed
and in particular I think it's worth
both Bill Clinton and the military
remembering that in many other fields
the military has a superb record the
best record of any institution we have
in this society of opening the doors for
many minorities it's done it superbly
well with regard to blacks it's done
increasingly well with regard to women
despite the tailhook incident and I
think that it will be a real tragedy if
that were lost in this process if the
military comes across as too homophobic
if the military sounds too intolerant
military ought to learn a lesson from
what happened the Republicans in Houston
the use of the people the Republicans
euston had some legitimate arguments to
make but they made them in such an
intolerant way they they alienate a
great number of people the military
shouldn't blow this it should handle
this with sensitivity as well I think it
can be done and remember that people
made the same arguments about blacks
before they were brought into the
military by Harry Truman in the late 40s
people made exactly the same arguments
going to lower morale they're going to
be resignations my god we can't handle
this they the blacks are now in and
there's some of the best performers
Naboth there is no question about it I'd
be happy to agree with almost all of
that actually a slight correction that's
what's in disguise I mean what isn't the
blacks weren't in the Army before
President Truman is so they were in
where they were segregated around
earlier and already said you don't know
when I went to Saudi Arabia during the
run-up to the unforgettably horrible a
Desert Storm will in fact the
forgettable horrible desert snow as we
should not think of it I mean I was very
impressed is to wonder what the Saudis
thought of the United States going just
by the army because the Army was
sticking up for the rights of Jewish
soldiers to celebrate Yom Kippur in the
desert when Saudi Arabia doesn't allow
you to be a Jew it was letting women
drive trucks when Saudi
doesn't let women drive anything and it
was integrated and multicultural and all
the rest of it who gave very good
impression of the United States a better
impression I think in the war did and
it's just occurred to me as mr. GaN was
talking that it actually if the military
was to take a forward and enlightened
position on this issue it would be as it
has on other matters putting the rest of
the society to shame it should be a good
thing David Gerken we are comments
please on the Hillary Clinton stories
the election is over why is her role
being discussed now haha well I did it
say again i-ight I'm going to animate
some some conservative friends on this
but nonetheless there there are many
many people in this country are choosing
sides and what kind of role Hillary
Clinton ought to play there are many
traditionalists who feel that she should
be first lady
first and foremost and she should take
play a very traditional role there are
many professional women who feel that
she can break a lot of set a lot of new
precedents here by showing what a
professional woman can do in that job
and I happen to believe to come down on
the side of saying this society is
changing rapidly I think Hillary Clinton
can make a substantial contribution by
continuing to show and act out as a
professional woman that does not mean
she has to be in the cabinet there's
there's a law in fact against that the
president under under laws passed after
Bobby Kennedy's service under Jack
Kennedy when Bobby Kennedy was named
Turney general there was a law passed
which said that the president cannot
appoint any relative to a job of which
he has jurisdiction of which he has
essentially command so she can't serve
in the cabinet I don't think she can
serve in the White House post onto that
but that does not mean she can't play a
substantial constructive even
provocative role on public policy issues
she cares deeply about such as children
david gergen and christopher hitchens
our guest this monday morning we go to
the phones in about 16 minutes for your
telephone calls from around the country
the other story referenced in that piece
i mentioned earlier was mister clinton's
trip to washington and in writing about
it in the washington times over the
weekend Ronald Taylor writes that
mr. there's a expert on the presidency
named Harold Barger and he wrote a book
called the impossible presidency
examining how Ronald Reagan used imagery
and communication skills to fashion a
successful presidency and he sees
elements of mr. Reagan's success in mr.
Clinton's early public appearances as
president-elect well I don't know what
mr. Hitchens who agrees with this or not
but I happen to believe that of their
last few presidents the one who got off
the best start was Ronald Reagan and I
think he captured this town I think he
said his agenda I think he captured
public imagination early on and he did
that by coming in with a very clear
focus and very clear sense of what he
wanted to accomplish it's been striking
to me that the Clinton folk and going
back and reviewing the very brief
presidencies have decided that Jimmy
Carter is not the model that they want
to follow and that Ronald Reagan is the
model they're going to school in the
Reagan experience that's tremendous
confession for them to make in my
opinion if that's if that is the case
because the the judgment of the voters
surely has just been that taking one
consideration with another the Reagan
period was a failure I mean that there
was smoke and mirrors and that was about
it that it was it was an illusion a
period of fraud and that it only went on
as long as it did because it's PR was
good I didn't see the P I was all that
great but obviously I was in the
minority however you think about this
for the first time if that's if that's
really true that they think the Reagan
president is the one to build on then it
would be the most visible possible start
I think can I respectfully disagree I I
have an interest in this because I did
serve Ronald Reagan early on many
conservatives believe that this vote had
nothing to do with Reagan and in fact
there's no such thing as the Reagan Bush
period there are the Reagan years and
something very separate apart from that
there are the Bush years and they feel
that this election was about the Bush
years and that the reason George Bush
lost was in very large measure because
he walked away from what Reagan was all
about that he bent and much of what
Reagan was all about and that got what's
got him in trouble so that they don't
see this vote is that having anything to
do with Reagan AOC
I mean to do with the experiment that
occurred unto the Bush presidency yeah
that's something that's I think that's a
damage control position I mean I know
that it's it's held by a lot of people
but I mean Bush is obviously more than
just the adopted son of Reagan he was
Reagan's right hand there was no real
discontinuity in their policies I can't
leave anything major thing Bush did that
Reagan would not have done well Reagan
stood for but they're not always honor
lower spending lower taxes lower
regulation Bush presided over higher
spending higher taxes higher regulation
regulations are 26% during the Bush
years up sharply from what they were in
the Reagan years nonetheless I think I
mean wouldn't it be fair to say that the
verdicts of the electorate most recent
it was in favor of an activist
government or a government that was
concerned with and felt confident that
it could do something about people's
lives I mean whether you believe in mr.
Clinton's actual proposals or not it was
a verdict surely for the for the
principle the government should be
involved it was an engine that do
nothing
Isak respect to the Reagan and Bush said
it stood forth there as you say hadn't
stood up for particularly consistently
III think the vote was one in favor of
economic growth and if it takes
government to bring economic growth so
be it and people felt that George Bush
was bringing neither what they did feel
under Reagan was they did have economic
growth and they voted for him
overwhelmingly in 84 and put him back
into office and they reelected and they
led then then voted it for his successor
in 88 let me get back to the concept of
change because there's a story I found
in this this weekend reflects a remark
you made about the Pamela Harriman
dinner and this is Richard Burke's
column and the New York Times over the
weekend
Dateline Little Rock and he writes it
was bound to happen sooner or later even
as Clinton aides are still giddy over
victory rumblings of dissension in the
ranks while no one dares register a
complaint for the record several Clinton
aides admit they were not altogether
pleased that at a time when populist
symbols could not be more important mr.
Clinton attended a Washington dinner
hosted by Pamela Harriman probably the
most elite of the elite Democratic
at dinner caught your attention as well
yeah because it seemed to me that if if
Clark Clifford for example wasn't in a
bit of bother with the law in the moment
and he would be well in the middle of
the shard at the moment and that it is
it is extraordinary to me that the
rhetoric of change which I began by
saying I thought was a bit shadow to
begin with I mean anyone can be in favor
of change and it's impossible to in
favor of things staying the same because
they weren't but the heretic of change
should be so disposable seemed bizarre
to me that whatever one at that dinner
should be someone who's been on the
bipartisan tracts a party of government
that really runs the city all the time
and that to offset this what five
minutes walk about on Georgia Avenue I
mean that's pretty vestigial isn't it
David Gege let me read you a comment
that one of the Clinton aides said in
response to this quote I wouldn't want
official Washington to be lulled into a
false sense of security he said anyone
who thinks that Bill Clinton is going to
be co-opted is pretty naive but the aid
was not confident up to be quoted by
name on well we're going to see more
stories like that I'm sure in the future
I have a somewhat different take on this
at listen Bill Clinton went out spent an
hour to an hour and a half on Georgia
Avenue this is a man who really was
clearly I think it more energized by
going to Georgia Avenue here and in the
inner city DC than he was by going to
the White House and meeting with George
Bush well it well I well you talk to the
Clinton people on you I think that's
where the man really gets his emotional
highs as we're going out not many sizes
off of John Patterson well no but I
thought I always bush in the White House
wouldn't be vandalizing I think it was
probably more important to him his real
center and where he what he cares about
is out there on the streets that's where
he draws his emotional energy from and I
you know I think we're gonna see a lot
of him on the streets it's also true
that I think he has to in order to
succeed here while nourishing that base
that populist base he has to he has to
be able to work within the power centers
and move the Washington power centers in
Washington George Jimmy Carter came to
town with this notion that he could
simply pay attention everything outside
of Washington and ignore official
Washington and kick it in the tail when
he wanted to and he got the you know he
got booted out of here because he did
not they did not work Washington while
also working the outside I think
Clinton's trying to do both it's going
to be hard it's going to be hard to do
it do it all and succeed but I think
he's at least trying is the underlying
question of this will that Washington
change the Clintons or will Clinton the
Clintons change wassail well I did go to
mr. Chen's point I think if Washington
winds up changing the Clintons and they
do become establishment inside insiders
then I think they're gonna have a
problem I think he's got to be able to
work with it but not be captured by and
just on this point of precedent images
we were talking about before role models
to use my least favorite phrase isn't it
more the Kennedy style that Clinton is
still attempting while in office as he
did on the campaign trail I'm not trying
to acquit him of this Reagan charge to
the pound even his defenders are making
but the plunging into the crowd on
Georgia Avenue had a very Bobby Kennedy
feel to me and I was looking up
something I was writing the other day
for by the Rhodes Scholarships and their
importance in American politics and I
discovered interesting fact there were
11 Rhodes Scholars and the Kennedy
administration hmm I think it's quit
which is I think the record so far Dean
Rusk being the best known of them I
think it's quite likely the cleanser
will break that record and I think it's
I think it's always the Kennedy paradigm
that he has in mind we ask you a
question I want to tell the audience
something first c-span has a camera crew
right now in Great Britain right now
over this couple of days we are in
Ireland where the Irish elections are
about to take place once that is over we
will travel next week to England and the
whole idea is to understand Rhodes
Scholarships oh and we will be going on
campus talking with people who run the
program trying to understand whether not
sure will own them in a strangely
neglected book that I wrote well find
you maybe I'll send you a copy okay well
but our point is of it is to find out
whether in fact there is a point of view
that one develops by being a Rhodes
Scholar is there well I would say what I
say in the book is yes the point of view
of the liberal imperialist how useful
this will be to the leader of the free
world I don't know but I mean I think
that's that's very much what the the
Rhodes Scholarship existed to do is to
give an anglo-american pattern of
confidence to to what they hope would be
a sub transatlantic working class of the
future and there are world scholars and
administration to be or the transition
team where president-elect the
president-elect of course a number of
his crucial advisors I think that maybe
the most famous is well a racial course
his economic transition team had and on
that transition team there at least two
other Rhodes Scholars I can think of by
name I was a doctor at the same time as
some of these guys so I remember for
example IRA Magaziner as a name that I
recall from those days I didn't know the
president-elect I think Derek Shira may
have been a Rhodes Scholar to is a right
there are quite a number of them and on
the injured the election campaign there
were four or five as well I just say
that that George Stephanopoulos his
communications director he looks person
hears a rally as a former wrestler and I
don't quite think he'd be in the liberal
imperialist tradition is there is there
a point of view or something that people
should should be on the lookout for with
people who are Ivy League graduates or
graduates of the Oxford Road scholarship
program well I think that I think that
there's a conspiratorial view out there
that somehow they all run in a pack and
they try to rule the world through
things like the Trilateral Commission
and Bilderberg and Council on Foreign
Relations and that sort of thing and
does a ladies also founded by the way
with the help of money from sessile read
write but but I still I don't think that
that's that's true I'd be associated
with some of those things and I do think
what it did for Bill Clinton the road
scholarship experience as best I can
tell was it made him more than a
nationalist and in fact I think there
have been a good deal that had he not
spent a couple of years abroad and been
exposed to that and become a committed
Atlantis as someone who's committed to
international trade that sort of thing I
think he would had a tougher campaign
because a lot of people have said yeah I
think he might have had a much more
inward view what about America's role in
the world isn't he I think that was a
valuable experience for him six minutes
until phone calls for our two guests a
reminder if you are a regular c-span
viewer that we do have a 30-day policy
that means you can't phone in this
morning if you've called any of our
programs within the past month you know
we do that so we can keep the mix of
opinions coming into our programs here
one person who was very visible over the
weekend this gentleman whose photograph
is on the front page of The New York
Times today Jesse Jackson who
met with Bill Clinton in Little Rock
over the weekend and Reverend Jackson
was also a guest on John McLaughlin
program over the weekend he saw a number
of articles tell me what your
perspectives are on this visit
interesting that came after the election
and not before the election it was it
was clear that mr. Clinton was keeping
his distance from Jesse Jackson prior to
and it's also clear that Jesse Jackson
now realizes who has the upper hand in a
relationship and he wants to go and heal
the heal there what rift existed there -
Jesse Jackson was very angry at Bill
Clinton during a early portion of the
campaign half over the sister souljah
incident there are many in the Clinton
campaign you believe in retrospect that
incident helped him enormously and
giving him some distance and also
showing that he could say no Christopher
Hitchens let me read to you a piece from
bill Nichols in USA Today it he writes
aides to both men are skeptical that
this kind of love fest will continue
once the new administration begins
making decisions less liberal and
sweeping than Jackson prefers you know
there's a thing that people said about
Tenzin practically every day during the
campaign which was he's always trying to
please everybody and I used to say why
do they say that when it's so obvious
that he will go out of his way to
displease Jesse Jackson also thought it
was a significant choice on Clinton's
part but the work there was more than
sister souljah episode there were a
couple of other times during the
campaign when he he quite obviously
wanted in a sense Jackson to look at
least offended and and this succeeded
and I think that Jackson Reverend
Jackson must notice that and noticed
that he was preferred in this case and
people like Sam Nunn and others were
were not is a suggestive choice of
enemies we are talking about the
transition and there are two hats to a
transition there are stories in the
paper and in other news magazines about
decisions still needing to be made by
the Bush administration before it leaves
the White House one of those is a
decision about the airlines and policy
would
you explain a little bit about how
important they are and some of the
politics of some yet unmade policy
decisions
well the III think that people at first
the public at large was was somewhat
taken aback by the by the notion that
but the bush people seem to say we have
no responsibility for anything we're
essentially shutting down the shop here
and we're going to go on vacation in the
last few days at least they've started
to get back in the ball game intend and
look like they're running the government
again I think people feel they need a
government and they don't want to hiatus
for two months the the most significant
decisions well one is with regard to the
airlines presumably that could be undone
but it but it's also which way they come
down is going to important this has to
do with a the fact that some foreign
companies are coming here with trying to
form a partnership with the US air and
that the other major airlines in this
company in this country brilliantly
district to the agreement because I
think it's going to it's unfair and it's
going to be tilted toward giving the
foreign carriers a greater access to
American markets and it gives American
carriers access to European that it's
not it's a tough decision for the
government to make but I think frankly
longer-term is in foreign policy where
some some bigger bigger issues exist one
is over what's happening in Russia with
Yeltsin increasing trouble the
Parliament of Russia are getting ready
to gather and and the West just doesn't
seem to be paying much attention to it
the others in bosnia-herzegovina billing
it and what's going on the former
Yugoslavia with with the deaths that are
going to be occurring there whereas Co
weather approaches slaughter that's
going on there and the West again not
doing very much about it it does seem to
me those are two areas where the Clinton
team and the bush team have an interest
in coming together and trying to form
some sort of joint understanding about
how they're going to deal with this
because it think that in the United
States at this point is appears to be
sitting on the sidelines and with
people's lives very much at stake
I want to see what will happen about the
official crime wave that's been taking
place under the Bush Reagan
administration there are a whole number
of inquiries into the remnants of the
iran-contra connection into the
increasingly sinister rocket
ramifications into a BNL into BCCI into
bad savings and loan connections with
some of these the retiring president is
under some pressure to sort of issue a
broad pardon and cancel all these
inquiries and I think it'll be a real
test of him if he does that look a great
chess to the Clinton Justice Department
in coming as to whether or not it goes
for a wound healing process and a whole
series of Pardons and leniencies or not
I saw fascinating letter in the New York
Times Osprey from mrs. procaster calling
for a pardon for caspar weinberger for
example delicious or social touch I
think it'd be very important that these
inquiries not be not be stalled that
they be in County through to the end and
I think it'll be a very important test
for both incoming and outgoing and
something to watch for something that
will genuinely be defining - here's
another term that gets me done we have
put a number of topics on the table but
it's time now to invite you to
participate in our discussion and again
we will put the numbers up on the screen
throughout this hour of telephone calls
as you can imagine our lines are very
busy here this morning but if you do get
a ringing sounds stay with it and we'll
answer your telephone call just before
it's time to put you on the air our two
guests this morning Christopher Hitchens
and David Gorgon first question for them
is from Baton Rouge Louisiana
good morning caller good morning when I
have would like address is the issue of
gays in the military from an economic
standpoint and my question is that
because they are being allowed to marry
in certain states and other things I
know that they are tested for the AIDS
virus when they come in and on a
periodic basis but if they should choose
the spouse to marry that has already
been infected and also they are allowed
to adopt children in certain state and
they would adopt people and they would
become infected then what would this do
to the economic standpoint of our
country so thanks very much caller Chris
Richards um I think it was there's a
slight free association going on in that
question confusion of categories I mean
for example if you have the AIDS virus
it doesn't mean that someone you adopt
is going to get it I mean
please we know better than that by now I
I think the question is about whether
you can not only be openly gay in the
Armed Forces but openly gay married to
someone else's openly gay and in the
Armed Forces
as far as I can see that's not at the
moment the problem is it that's not the
question of your face yeah I think this
is the kind of question of many
Americans have and because there is a
good deal of people are just fearful in
this area they don't know what's going
to happen and they're worried about what
consequences I think them I think the
military and must one need to be very
responsive and open about these kind of
issues is I understand the issue and
perhaps I have this wrong but I guess
it's my understanding there are many
gays ok gays and lesbians in the
military forces today they are there
undercover there they're secretly
because if they disclose their sexual
preferences they'll be they'll be booted
out and in fact the government now
spends a lot of money trying to find
them we spent five hundred million
dollars unbelievably over the course of
the 80s trying to find gays the military
but there are many there now and what
the military now does is that it tests
Susan everybody in the military for HIV
every six months and it doesn't make
theirs because of course heterosexuals
become to get AIDS too so everybody is
tested and that practice will continue
and the people who are infected will be
in fact separated out and I think so I
think the military already has a
forward-looking policy regard to AIDS
that that will not change if gays or if
the ban on gays is lifted in fact I
think the military is already well ahead
on this on this particular side of the
question you mentioned the Newsweek poll
earlier and it's dealing with the
public's perception of the Clinton
transition it also asks a question about
this issue engaged in the military and
it's right here at the very bottom of
this piece James if you can bring the
camera in public support for Clinton's
plan to drop the ban on homosexuals and
the Armed Forces has declined sharply
from 59% in August to just 48% but more
than half felt homosexual should be
allowed to hold jobs in Clinton's
cabinet well let that stand and take a
call Portland Maine is on the air good
morning good morning first-time caller
glad to have you on the air sir which
questions I'm like well I have a couple
comments in my question my first comment
real quick I thought the media bias was
terrible though she had worse with
parole second the mandate that Clinton
supposedly got I think is is weak at
best if if you take all the people that
voted for him because they didn't like
Saukville
or they voted for him because I thought
Perot was going to be in his cabinet
he's really weak my question is where
does the homosexuals in the military if
if there's a tremendous amount of
retirements where does all that calm in
the budget in the fiscal part where
would that is that all funded or you
know I'll hang up and listen to your
comment I would you explain the linkage
between the question and retirement well
you know if there's there's a tremendous
amount of people who retire or decide to
you know not renew and stay in the
military and there's a retirement what
is that all funded or is it something
that you know in the budget process
where does that come out of all right
thanks thanks very much for the call
Portland Maine your response light in
the toughest well I think if if I
understand the question correctly that
may not it is whether if there is a
massive resignation from the military
whether that's going to drive up the
cost of the pension system of course it
would
and theirs out but I think that the
fears of a mass resignation are
overstated I you're you may have some
resignations but I think that there is a
I think people isn't to go back to mr.
Hitchens point earlier people have lived
with gays in our society a long time now
there are a lot of them here in our in
you know they are part of the American
face today and I think I think people
are much more sophisticated about this
and I would be very surprised if their
big mass resignations Christopher
Hitchens that callers first comment was
about press coverage during the campaign
Betsy Kolbert of the New York Times
wrote about it over the weekend
here is the headline on her piece maybe
the media did treat Bush a bit harshly
you think there was a media bias during
this last campaign yeah
I thought ever since I went up to New
Hampshire in fact I thought that I'd
never seen a more obvious press
consensus that you know we found a
candidate who still like us and we
summer we can get behind and that
candidate was governor of Clinton I
thought it was extraordinary through the
primaries extraordinary at the
convention where he simply had to say
look this is how I would like to be
perceived and they would as it were so
perceive him and sort of almost
laughable towards the end of the
campaign I saw I think it was Evan
Thomas of Newsweek that admit as much on
on CNN which was admirable of him but a
lot of journalists refused to cop to the
fact that some of them may not even have
known that they were walking around in
two days of love for governor Kent and
they missed him still they're doing set
I've written in US news that I thought
that the press was unfair to George Bush
in this campaign I thought it was very
sympathetic to mr. Clinton particularly
in the fall I think that's in part true
because the early in the primaries the
press brutalized Bill Clinton I think
we're extraordinarily unfair to Bill
Clinton early on over his personal life
Jennifer flowers and the rest and I in
terms of Tennessee had to lay back from
that and said everything he said about
that story every single thing I think we
eyes out without question tradition I
think we became a lap dogs of the of the
sensationalist press we printed it and
and went to press with tons of stuff
without telling the public that that
gennifer flowers tape was a cooked tape
it was an edited version of whatever we
don't know of the authenticity even to
this day and you're going back to your
60 minutes thing the reason he had to go
on 60 minutes and talk about his
personal life was he had no choice a man
was being handed handed to death you
know so I think that there was press was
unfair to Clinton early on but I think
it turned around but let me just come
after this other point you know if you
really want to know who the toughest
critics in the press were they were not
on the Left who guarded mr. Bush they
were on the right the conservative
commentators were far tougher on George
Bush and were the liberal commentators
and I think that's in part because the
conservatives were more disappointed
they had believed that what that Bush
would be a content content continuation
of Reagan and they felt let down by and
they really went after him
in the long run I don't think it was the
press that cost the president the
election whether it's left or right it
was the economy no look I've really
anxious not to contribute to that myth
either in the to the headline you held
out miles would be no the press wasn't
unfair to bush I said we said it was
biased in favor of Bill Clinton and Bush
deserved far worse than the press that
he got and deserved that I think from
the moment he took the oath of office
that he later betrayed my bet my
favorite example I think would be that
if it wasn't for for Lawrence Walsh the
press never would have called him on his
open lying about iran-contra about his
his oath to defend the Constitution and
his violation of that and I'm sorry I
mean I send me to say that that there
will be people who say that the press
was laying for Bush and otherwise he'd
have been related that's all nonsense
but it is it is still true to say that
the press rooted and continues to root
for Bill Clinton Los Angeles good
morning you're on the air good morning
Susan are you going to pick up the
English side of the Iraq 8 debate that
scheduled for today I think interesting
to see I think it's scheduled for today
in Parliament Bob Christopher I would
like to know if you if you've dropped
October Surprise or if you're so
interested in the remnants of that and
did you hear James Fallows on NPR last
week make a proposal that Bush
recognized Vietnam and that and the
Clinton then veto some of of these
characters like like Weinberger as each
each president doing something the other
was find very difficult to do and what
do you think of that I think it's not a
bad idea I just want to know what
happened was that I want to see these
people go to jail um and I and he said
thrown up to the historians I would also
throw into the deals that I think that
the bush should finish up the Mideast
peace talks because I don't think the
Palestinians can hope for much from Bill
Clinton but it okay that's that's a good
a good series of questions I mean I let
me draw up the one thread I was just
thinking this morning as mister Baker
leaves office under cloud for the dirty
work that he was involved in in the
champagne I thought he'll probably
escape the blame for it he arranged to
represent himself as having been
adequately uninformed and that'll mean
that he he leaves just the way he began
when he was Reagan's campaign manager
and was involved in the theft of Jimmy
Carter's briefing book which is of
course to come to a question one of the
building blocks for the October Surprise
theory that yes there was collusion
between the Reagan Bush campaign and the
ayatollahs hostage takers which I'm
perfectly satisfied there was the most
recent evidence for it I think comes in
the long piece in The New Yorker by
Craig Unger and Mary wasps that was run
in the closing days of the campaign
about about the encouragement by George
Bush of Iraq to bomb deep inside Iran so
the Iran would need to come to the
United States to buy weapons in other
words it's the usual pattern of divide
and rule in the Middle East using
hostages in the arms sales as the
currency and leading finally and of
course to divide and rule within America
itself into huge and continuing
violations of the Constitution to your
last point I want both to find out what
happened on I want to see them go to
jail for inch and I think there's no
need for a horse trade on that about
Vietnam or anything else though I think
it would be very nice if Bill Clinton
was to announce very early in his
presidency that he would go to Vietnam
and recognize the government there I
want to apologize to Vietnam for what's
been done to it and to the continuing
insults that are heaped on it by people
like mr. Poirot there are so many points
I wish I bigger estate disagree but I'm
not sure where to begin but if I can if
you permit me a moment I and I should
say I have a biasness issue because I
did work for James Baker and he was a
mentor of mine he remains a friend and I
have enormous ly high regard for him to
to I think I think that is to conclude
that he leaves office under any cloud is
wrong I think he has done distinguished
service for this country I don't think
he had again to go all the way back to
the beginning there was no theft of the
Carter briefing book the what came over
was a because I was updated
it was it was a was a set of papers that
the Carter people somebody in the Carter
campaign provided to the Reagan campaign
that had no value and they were not
stolen by the Reagan campaign filter
done there was nothing unethical to
Congress investigated other people
investigated Baker was cleared everybody
was cleared and to go he was cleared it
was the obstacle he had by the elbows to
filibuster come in lined out they
couldn't find anything I don't know what
you want to do I mean you have to prove
a negative but you've got the you can't
simply smear people in the public press
and in the media by saying it wasn't
resolved and therefore they're guilty
that's unfair to the people it refers
everyone like they were kids it wasn't I
can't say that well it but you can't
keep coming up and say that somehow a
man was guilty of something it just
seems be extraordinarily unfair to the
person I mean if he's found guilty under
our light I know it takes a lot to make
me cry okay who told who told these
hacks in the State Department to act
like a banana republic set of officials
and politicized their job as possible
there is no there is no maker of course
we'll arrange there would be no where
will this happen when there is no
evidence that mr. Baker had anything to
do with this what the evidence have ever
investigation so far is that it was it
was the people who were overzealous at
the State Department exactly well wait a
minute but they were overzealous and
that there was nobody in the upper ranks
and knew about it the people in the
upper ranks told him to do it by the
book in a routine fashion and to bring
in lawyers and make sure everything was
handled protecting if you think you've
obviously anything that sets a banana
republic explanation of banana republic
day but if it's always some lower but if
you believe that somebody something by
getting their name in the papers and
have a suspicion raised about them is
guilty based on suspicion and people who
want to raise us it's unfair to the
individual people serve in public life
and try to serve this country well there
are some people who are criminals
there's no doubt about that but every
time it some name arises and has some
suspicion attached to it to say
automatically they're guilty i think is
is is it extraordinary outrageous let me
jump in just take a call from
Lawrenceville Georgia good morning
caller hi I'm a flight humorous
interjection here to these detention I'm
a neo liberal imperialist Democrat
living here in the heart of Newt
Gingrich country and I suggest that
the Clinton campaign and Bill have lunch
tomorrow instead of going to make them
in Albany also come up here and have
lunch at the Gwinnett Place Mall this
county went this is a strongest
Republican County it went 1/3 Democrat
in two thirds Republican and he can get
enough votes tomorrow to bring white
Fowler back to the Senate I want to also
comment on what's going on in Europe I
was for Tsongas then I was for Perot and
I love Clinton I didn't think Clinton
had a chance because of all that press
brouhaha in January in February but this
is what this is a cynical Machiavellian
analysis of what's going on in Europe
and reference to our four trillion
dollar debt and it's simply that as long
as there's chaos in Europe neo Nazism in
Germany and ethnic cleansing and in the
ex-soviet Union and Yugoslavia the
dollar is being propped up I am scared
witless about it and the flight and the
fright capital is propping up the
American dollar and that's why I was for
Perot for a while I'd ever signed his
petition I wasn't that stupid but he
certainly made a point and so did
Tsongas about it I believe now this is
off the wall and I apologize for it but
we're going to have to do something
extremely radical and that would be in
my opinion a 99 year lease of the
Federal part of Alaska for two trillion
dollars and I would like to be a green
but I would also like to save this
country and if our financial system
collapses the whole world collapses
thank you sir a lot of issues here why
don't we start with the Georgia Senate
race if we could because that's Tuesday
and we were looking at the headline both
parties are sending people from the
national level down on this race how
important is it to each of the parties
it's important it's not as obviously as
important as the as a general election
and I think that Bill Clinton finally is
going down there to campaign it seems me
could have been even more active in this
campaign on behalf of white Fowler the
incumbent Democrat is up for re-election
and again a close close runoff the
Republicans have sent people in it is a
Clinton's going in today too
I don't know what the outcome is going
to be it it is not it's important if
Bill Clinton went if the Democrats win
this it will help Clinton modestly in
the Senate because the old wife father
will be terribly indebted to him and
it'll be a nice little boost for the
Clinton during the transition if the
Republicans win they're going to they're
gonna have a bit of a bit in their teeth
and feel better about the the next few
months Christopher Hitchens will you
respond to that caller on his
international comments foreign policy I
was glad that he mentioned ethnic tens
even though he located it in the wrong
in the wrong country where he later
Croatia so I think that I wish we would
divert a minute or two perhaps this
should be the minute to what's happening
in Bosnia can I say a word about it um I
was in Surrey over in the in the suburb
and in other parts of Bosnia too and
I've never seen really anything like it
I didn't sufficiently understood in this
country that unlike say Somalia people
often compare the two tragedies and say
oh well you know what can you do in
Bosnia Herzegovina there's an organized
attempt actually to physically destroy a
people by force
partly on the grounds of their religion
which is predominantly Muslim and if
this is allowed to go on excuse me I
want to get overwrought about it if this
is allowed to go on the Muslim world
will never forgive it and they'll be
right not to forgive it so the stakes I
think they're reasonably high and we
often ask ourselves you know how did in
the 30s people get away with it how is
it that people you know pretended they
didn't know what was going on this is
actually happening on our screens and
before our eyes and we keep being told
by the NATO riots which has huge power
in the area there isn't really much we
can do about it I don't think that
explanation should be accepted can the
West do something about the situation
yes it can yeah and if Europe had more
guts it would have done something about
it before this it was it was understood
some more than a year ago that this was
primarily going to be a European
solution
they sent a bunch of diplomats in there
but they were they they refused to take
any kind of meaningful action and I
think it's gotten it's gotten worse as a
result I think the United States should
step in now mr. Hitchens is absolutely
right about that the West should do more
this is a tragedy that's unfolding
before us
and if it takes them take some selective
bombing by the West to do to calm the
Serbs down and pull back out of there I
think ministration is absolutely right
we ought to be looking at that very hard
and do it more than halfway through our
program with our two special guests next
Portland Maine on the air
good morning fish man good morning sir
morning good morning mr. gergan one of
my favorite commentators thank you one
brief comment and two-part question
the gays in the military should be a
non-issue I wish that wise Cowboys made
and I speculate that we had a Republican
administration and Republican Congress
for a Democratic president as we will
have and Democratic Congress they almost
wouldn't matter solvents would get
solved pretty well I think regardless
booth philosophy was in charge and I
wonder how efficient is the
parliamentary system thank you very much
thank you very much well we're going to
find out right now whether it you know
it with one party in charge here whether
it makes a big difference in I I all of
us course hope that it does it it
unfortunately last time we tried this
during the Carter years it didn't seem
to work out all that well that there
were factions within the Democratic
Party that prevented mr. Carter from
moving forward a lot of issues but
perhaps this will be better well we'll
have to wait and see and I think that
for the time being there's obviously a
love fest going on but one of the
Clinton people even call it a Love Shack
here last week when Clinton was in town
so I just I just think we ought to get
you know give the mr. Clinton and is in
the Democrats have benefited out until
they until they have a chance to come in
here and prove themselves Christopher
Hitchens that caller wonders whether
countries with the parliamentary system
are governed differently more
effectively I guess was the nature of
his question um well I come from another
zoo probably tell and I wish that the
United Kingdom had your our Constitution
certainly the Bill of Rights in return I
think a nice trade would be a
parliamentary question time whether it
should be executives has to actually go
unrehearsed and explain to Congress what
is going on
c-span actually has helped by
transmitting Westminister question
trying to create demand for this the
United States and I believe congressmen
guidance and from Connecticut is
sponsoring a bill to that effect I
really hope that that happens I think
nothing could be more sanitary than the
president knowing that he has to go
without a script and defend his policies
before an educated combative audience so
yes that that aspect of parliamentary
tradition I think would travel quite
well we have question time on Larry Cain
fell down here yes that's true
but Brian lamb obregón Brian lamb but
it's not the same as going into the bear
pit you know how villain and other prime
ministers used to feel quite ill
beforehand was a test they knew they
even mother touch it was a test she knew
she couldn't fake every week Los Angeles
is on the air I have a question for
Hitchens and one for gergan the one for
Hitchens I'm just wondering who
subsidizes the left wing in this country
I think if you weren't a very safe left
winger who can huff and puff and make a
lot of noise that they that the
establishment realizes is going to
result in nothing you'd never be allowed
to speak by say the new house chain
which I didn't new house who owns Vanity
Fair and I the publisher of the nation
was on c-span and he looked like a very
safe capitalist I'd you know all this
left-wing huh free and puffery is is is
that a lot of fun for you but you get
paid well for it it's an easy it's an
easy job also I would like to ask I
would also would like to ask a gergan
arm that you feel that the press was
hard extremely hard on George Bush now
this is just a matter of style
but what if what if what if Carter had
thrown up on the on the Prime Minister
of Japan what would they have done with
and they would have shown that photo
over there would have shown that
sequence over and over again
what if Carter had called his opponents
bozo and ozone man what would the press
have done with that uh it would have
been it would have been non-stop uh you
know solemn heads talking about it and
and this remember when Carter stumbled
and fell when he was on a jog that shot
was shown over and over again it might
not have the the prime-minister thing
might not have been fair but it
certainly if it had been a Democrat it
would have been over and over again
thanks caller christopher hitchens we'll
start with you I agreed we loved that I
did yeah I think I did I mean I think
it's probably all the other I mean I
have the impression I did see the bush
launching his lunch at the Japanese a
little bit more than once
uh-huh frame buffer Alfred buffer and
well paid for it yeah that's fine of its
it's a terrific living I wouldn't
consider myself lucky person and and the
capitalist finances in order to have it
fun and games for their further further
populist oh no I thought she just said
that some the publisher the nation was
was a majestic capitis which is
certainly true off the cart it would not
mind I think that said about him right
well III tough caller you got some tough
calls in this on the question of Jimmy
Carter and and George Bush look at my
point and indeed is that I think the
press is is is is not is less
instinctively liberal that is that in
his sometimes it's instinctively
anti-establishment of particularly if a
president is in a little trouble and I
think you know there there's no question
that Jimmy Carter got a very rough press
in the last year or so of his presidency
and at that example when he was out
jogging in and and fell and stumbled and
became a metaphor for his whole
administration toward the end the idea
was Jody Powell his press secretary who
complained once toward the end of the
Carter Administration every time it
rained in Washington Carter got blamed
for it you know so I think that there is
this feeling that that over time if
you're president you can face icon
creasing Lee hostile press whether
you're Jimmy Carter or George Bush and
that in times that over time the press
can get indeed can get a little tired of
you as a story it's one of the but it's
one of the problems we have with
television age that everything is
disposable nothing lasts very long every
soap opera dies after a while
Cosby goes off the air after a while and
presents go off the air after a while
Miami you're on the air good morning
Susan good
gentlemen I have two quick questions
firstly if I remember correctly four or
five years ago when Dole was running
against bush there was quite a bit of
animosity between the two especially
dulled towards bush and I'm wondering
what happened in the last four years
that Dole was crying in his farewell
speech to Bush at a Press Club meeting
not too long ago secondly I'd like to
know what you think the future is of
Baker and Kemp in the next four years
and what kind of hints or indication
should we be seeing in the press as to
what they plan on doing in the next
presidential race thank you thanks very
much
I'd like to take the question on senator
Dole y'all never remember the waiter
looked in the camera and said as if
speaking directly to Bush remember that
and said stop lying by my record looking
really as if he disliked him I remember
being very struck by that too well I
think the answers to where it goes as it
goes he's a coal as a politician he he
wouldn't waste good hatred energy like
that if there was no obvious target for
it but I don't think he's some in any
sense
weeping since there cheers but
anything's that maybe the Republican
cause in general and to move to that and
to your question I think it is obviously
through the traq campus in a very strong
position to lead the comeback and I
still can't understand why when Quayle
offered to quit Bush didn't dump him
then in there and asked Quayle and asked
Kemp on the spot I understand bush and
cam never got onto every well but I did
you used to terrify me that that they
would work out that they could do that
in stay in power David Gerken you talked
about James Baker earlier there is one
article I'll tell the caller he's
interested in following up the New York
Times and this is Sunday again this is
on James Baker's future a star's future
dims Johnny Apple RW Apple writes his
image of political magic marred Baker
confronts uncertain prospects and you
can see this blowout here thoughts of
the presidency seem unrealistic
what about mr. Baker's political future
well I think that yeah I don't totally
disagree with the thrust of Johnny
Apple's article The Times I think that
mr. Baker's indicated in the last few
days that he intends to probably will
stay in Washington his daughter is here
in school and in high school he wants to
let her finish out here in school
there's been summit suggestions that he
might practice law here I think that in
fact this period of time when he served
came back his chief of staff during the
campaign did and he knew this when he
went in did hurt him politically it hurt
him because it was a no-win situation he
had a president who was hopelessly on
the ropes and he couldn't bring it back
he couldn't revive him and even evitable
a he was going to be blamed to share
some of the blame for the defeat he
wanted to go out as Secretary of State
he went out instead in a political
position so I think that it was there
was no there's no question that many
people around Jim Baker did not want him
to go back to the White House in this
second time around because they knew
exactly what was going to happen now
there is a residual respect for Baker
within the Republican Party in fact many
you know I think over time you'll find
that his voice will be one of the
important ones on the outside about
foreign policy and about the future of
the country in a private sector there
was a poll taken in New Hampshire a few
before this campaign got underway in
earnest of the Republican voters about
96 and in that poll
Dan Quayle got five percent of the vote
as I recall for preference for 96 Jim
Baker got about 35 and was at the top of
the poll even ahead of Jack Kemp
surprisingly enough and I do agree with
mr. Hitchens Jack Kemp nationwide is is
is the man to watch right now although I
think the future the Republican Party
has a lot more to do with whether it
comes up with ideas and whether it comes
up with new candidates well didn't you
think that Kemp made the most single
most revolutionary statement may join
the campaign who's it made during the
Republic intervention he was talking
about Los Angeles among other things but
he said if people have no property you
can't expect him to defend property
rights I thought that was an astonishing
thing to say that otherwise abysmal
convention and certainly something that
you wouldn't have been allowed to say at
the Democratic convention for fear of
seeming too radical so I regard campus
someone really worth watching I agree I
totally agree with that and it's been
interesting to me that I bill clinton in
many instances had moved over and
co-opted some of jak camps ideas David
Gergen is originally from Durham North
Carolina as a graduate of
in 1963 Harvard Law School in 1967 and
served for three and a half years in the
Navy on active duty before undertaking
his journalism career christopher
hitchens as we learned earlier is a
native of England Portsmouth England as
a matter of fact and is a graduate in
philosophy politics and economics from
Oxford University in 1970 you anticipate
going back to live in Great Britain at
some point no no it's true what they say
by the United States it's the land of
the free I wouldn't be immodest enough
to say was heaven with the brave but I
mean I I've never regretted for a minute
sign to move here very nicely to have me
Duluth Minnesota is next good morning
good morning
morning mr. gergan time' i might also an
admirer of yours for many years thank
you I I have a question I think as a as
a avid watcher of c-span during the
election it was like a war zone out here
it was just terrible many of us had
sense that the press usurped our
election and I think that's why we see
so much of this animosity repeated in
questioning after question my question
relates to what can we as a citizenry do
to turn this thing around
we still I think is an American public
are very gullible we want to believe
what is true we're not being told the
truth I wish the press would back off
comment has been made well we can just
turn the channels by then the damage is
done so my question is what can we do to
get to get things changed how can we
change the understanding of the press
with regard to what we feel happened to
us during this election is this
interactive can you can you elaborate a
ma'am on your on your thoughts about why
you thought the people lost control of
the election night I'm curious by that
because my impression was that in fact
the press had less control over this
than in past elections that was
particularly true of the major networks
as the candidates found these other
forums that they could communicate with
the citizenry in the question and answer
sessions whether what was on Larry King
or MTV or c-span or McNeal
or whatever it might have been and that
the citizens or the Richmond debate for
example in citizens came and asked
questions which has never happened
before but that was my interpretation
but you you obviously don't think that's
right no I I don't because I think those
were brief snippets if you will between
the other 24 hours a pounding of their
own particular agenda I was very much
impressed by that especially people who
aren't critical thinkers who rely on
your TV to tell the most of everything
that they know and many people who work
who follow the news just in the evening
who don't have time to see or read much
else listen to all of this stuff time
and again and this nd and the decided
impression was that Bush was not
believable that Clinton was the person
we needed to support I think that was
the underlying message and I think that
many of us feel regardless of what we
felt about the other candidates that
that this was just a tremendous pounding
if I say it felt like a warzone out here
too many oh well well I just to respond
to it strikingly mr. Hitchens and I
agreed that the press was much more
sympathetic to mr. Clinton than it was
to mr. Bush during this campaign I I
feel that the the more the public raises
its voice in these situations and more
it raises how in fact the better because
it's one thing you have to understand is
that while we in the press may seem want
to live monolithic and powerful in fact
we're very market sensitive these days
it's a very competitive business and the
press is paying just as the politicians
are trying to pay more attention to the
public I think the press is trying to
pay more attention to the public and I
think the more you raise your voice as
you just have the more helpful it is I
think it's very very healthy to stand up
and say we don't like this kind of
coverage we don't want it would you guys
please go away or just or get some new
people or just essentially give us the
facts and stop giving us all your biased
opinions or your opinion polls and your
opinion poll Majan if the coverage of
sorry I know you what influence isn't
but it imagine if the coverage every
night hadn't begun by telling you how
far ahead Bill Clinton was in some
notional poll
quite extraordinary I don't know how
much of a violation of the First
Amendment would be involved in this but
it seems to me it would be worth
considering doing what I know it's done
in France and I believe in Australia and
some other democracies just you can't
publish an opinion poll during the last
month of an election campaign
well I touched not allowed to tell
people how they have voted no III agree
with the point but I go back to your
original point there's a good reason we
had the Bill of Rights in this country
and I'm glad you liked it
Rapid City South Dakota good morning
first amendments my favorite ones here
good morning it's my first time calling
I heard mr. Hitchens or I believe it was
a caller earlier state that as mr.
Hitchens stated that he took umbrage
with mr. Bush's oath of office in that
with the iran-contra affair and all that
and he agreed with the previous caller
who stated that the homosexual issue in
in the military was a non-issue may I
also point out that all of us who enlist
or take the oath of commission in the
Armed Forces do so with the phrase it's
also in mr. Bush's oath that we have no
mental reservation and unfortunately
since it's against regulation and in
effect against the law to enlist or take
the oath of commission in the Armed
Forces knowing that you are homosexual
these people have already shown
themselves to be without honor they've
taken it with a mental reservation and
when they come forward they should
justly suffer the consequences thank you
sir Christopher Hitchens well that seems
to me to be inverting the the priority
of the question as we were discussing
here the poll point is should people be
forced to lead a double life what can it
not be honestly admitted that you wish
to defend your country or serving its
armed forces and to proclaim your sexual
preference or identity I mean the fact
that you can't do that now and your what
you're forced to be dishonest about it
or be discriminated against is precisely
what we're talking about I didn't in
that sense but by the way say that I
thought it was a non-issue I just
the ban is a is something that couldn't
be argued for if it did not exist David
Gerken you brought along a piece for us
to look at from the New York Post this
morning well I was interested in this I
I don't ordinarily promote the New York
Post but since my owner Mort Zuckerman
owns in the art they be news these days
but nonetheless it was an interesting
story in the post this morning of a
retired Navy captain who's who's in
effect come out and said it or not an
asleep mind you because he has to
protect his name and this that he had
been he was gay and that he in fact had
a quite a distinguished war record so I
I think we ought to be very very
cautious about essentially condemning
all gays as being unable to serve and
serve with distinction I think the
record will show that there been a lot
of them who have there is I think a
legitimate concern on the part of people
in the military about sexual behavior
within the ranks and I think that the
military has going to have to draw up
rules which are very tough on this
subject it there is a question of morale
morale or is a question of bonding and I
think it I think people who go into the
military have a right to expect that
they're not going to be harassed by
anybody if you're a woman in the
military you shouldn't be arrests and if
you're if you're a heterosexual male in
the military you shouldn't be a rat and
you shouldn't be exposed to things that
make you feel like you can't work
closely with the people next to you but
I think we're going to see an increasing
number of stories of people who have
been gay who have served well and I
think in fact have shown a lot of
courage and just the point of this whose
men considers as where the defence of
the realm and the orderly conduct of
military business remember what happened
with the USS Iowa surely wasn't it was
in New Jersey Iowan terrible explosion
terrific loss of life attempt by by
people in in the in the service to say
it was all because of homosexual love
affair leading everyone completely away
from what the important evidence was
actually if anything weakening the
defense of the country and doing heaven
knows watch a good order and discipline
and morale by trying to escape that
homosexuals the point is you know all
people who try and do that are pandering
to probably something they based in
themselves but certainly to the lowest
impressions of public opinion it's
always God
be a person I would've thought there was
a case for opposing it even more
strongly if you happen to love the Armed
Forces New Orleans you're on the air
good morning come on y'all
I'd like to know um I was born in
Argentina and I still receive newspapers
from there and they're very concern
about the Clinton victory and I think
the reason is because we never heard in
this country about what is calling
Argentina the youma gate I don't know if
you're familiar with it
the youma gate is the sister-in-law of
the President of Argentina Menon was
caught with suitcases full of money and
they think this is narco money drug
money and I never read nothing
you know and magazines here in the
States about it and Menon is concerned
because he was he has a very good
relations with Bush so you know I wonder
why we knew heard about it thank you
very much thank you for the call hmm I
don't have an easy answer for that the
impression is in this country that mr.
manometer a somewhat rough start is has
become a better President of Argentina
but perhaps because we've been
preoccupied but what's been going on in
Brazil I don't even know a difficulty on
certain items Fort Worth Texas you're
next hello hi I cannot believe the
attitude in this country about gay
people in the military when from we've
never had this problem I do believe that
president-elect Clinton should lift the
ban I don't think that it is fair for
the press to say that gays in the
military is not an important enough
issue this issue has only to do with the
disabled rights of persons and black arm
the issue of black civil rights was a
big issue in the sixties I do believe
and as far as this idea of morale is
concerned isn't the military asking
society to accommodate pre-existing
prejudices that indicate a lacking of
discipline and a willingness to
discriminate within the military itself
thanks very much David Gorgon you you
wrote about this in your column in US
news this week are you surprised at the
number of calls we've taken on sub
on the other no this this issue it's a
very raw nerve in the American public
and and you can pick it up almost
anywhere you travel around the country I
think the calls that you're getting
today or reflective of very strong
feelings that are that are in the
country about it I just want to come
back to one point because it's my very
clear where I think this ought to come
out the military has a superb record of
dealing with minorities and other people
it has been the the one of the most
important revolutions has taken place in
this country has has taken place in the
military over the last 20 years an
institution that was on its tail that
couldn't get its act together that
simply was having all sorts of internal
problems with strong leadership with a
vision of a equal opportunity and
becoming an effective fighting force
they have turned themselves around they
have a wonderful record they it is it's
the best educated group in the country
today they're well disciplined they have
they they're very goal-oriented they've
opened the doors to blacks I think the
military day they're many people in
military today who are some of our last
heroes they said they showed that in the
Gulf I think there are many people in
the military today who could go out into
our high schools and work with our kids
help them from dropping and keep it from
dropping out persuade them to to go
ahead and get their high school degree
and go on in life and it would be a real
shame if somehow that record were lost
to psych by this dispute over over gays
in the military I think the regular
military has a lot to teach us and
people in the mo there ought to be very
proud of what's accomplished been
accomplished there over the last 15
years it's marvelous marvelous record
and : Powell and others deserve a lot of
credit for that so it's important not to
lose sight of that and for the military
now to make the next step as fellow
civilian leadership Bill Clinton having
campaigned on this issue having gotten
elected without a big debate over this
issue you know I think he's going to
follow through on it and the question is
can the military make this next
adjustment I think it's capable of doing
that small plug in them in the
connivance affair there's a wonderful
picture by had to do with it so for
Pawlik Oakland that the Navy flyer who
was fouling this handle at the Taylor
convention by mob of young gentlemen and
we asked the question and of course
rightly should heterosexuals really be
allowed into into the armed forces in
such numbers Charlie Peters made a good
point about this DL
if you saw it said to know one of the
reasons people invent for saying dead
let's have gays in the military is they
say well you know wouldn't they harass
the the other guys and Charlie said well
after the Taylor convention that might
teach them because it would be good if
they knew how it felt to be set up on
ogled ah it's it's all broadening them
the frontiers I'm never going to find
that photograph in time so I'll move on
fantastic exists Seattle is on the air
good morning good morning yes I'd like
to address a preface and a question to
mr. Hitchens referring his earlier
comments on mr. Baker mr. Hitchens
tonight is on several occasions
attempted to instruct us on proper
constitutional behavior however his
character assassination of mr. Baker
earlier on is less reminiscent of Oxford
than it is of the best eventual
journalistic standards of least are you
leading this Tussaud question ah mr.
Hitchens how is it that after ten years
in this country you still have not
internalized the fact that in this
country a man is innocent until proven
guilty I'm an immigrant myself and that
was one of the very first things I
learned when I took the oath with the
agent was did you know that before
excuse me
didn't you know that before um well in
the country that I came from a bit
followed the European standard of being
guilty until proven innocent
this is one reason why I am here and I
hope this is one reason why you were
here yes well now close your question
would be only marginally less eccentric
than it is if you had mistaken me as
apparently you have for a court of law I
can put my hand on my heart and say I'm
not a court of law
I'm not even a policeman I'm not even a
lawyer I can't find anyone guilty but I
can make whatever presumptions I choose
as a journalist and if I think it's
really pitiful that you haven't
internalized that much of the First
Amendment in the law and apparently
profitless time you've spent here here
is the Paula Coughlin photograph from
Vanity Fair that Christopher Hitchens
was talking about earlier see if I can
hold this up and also take a call at the
same time Austin Texas go ahead please
hi I wanted to go back to the caller
that was on there earlier talking about
how when Bush threw up on the prime
minister and it
I have a hard time thinking that that
was that big of a topic for us to be
worrying about in an election along with
a the abortion issue and everything else
that seemed to have such an
overshadowing effect on the real issues
I think there's another thing that
happened during that election and it was
how they downplayed the economy making
it look worse than it was up until the
day after the election and and I kind of
think that the media and even the major
networks were kind of you know on
Clinton's side all the way through and I
do think the Perot helped him along in
that by showing a negative side towards
the bush administration thank you sir we
covered that didn't we well I'm just
curious about the economy reporting of
the economy did you see a underreporting
of or false reporting of the economic
indicators until a day after the
election or right after the election is
this caller said well I have to tell you
that the the press has been remarkably
more optimistic about the economic
outlook since the election than it was
before that and there was a time of
course when we had some numbers a third
quarter numbers it before the election
showing 2.7 percent growth the president
tried to trump at that and there was a
there was a real view within the press
that they were if they were cooked to
numbers at something they were fake
numbers and that they'd been trumpeted
for the election so I think that the I
think the caller has a point on that I
do disagree with him about the about the
importance of abortion I do think it's
an important issue for an enormous
number of people in this country here is
Christopher Hitchens column in the
December issue of Vanity Fair it unders
his heading cultural elite this topic is
mr. universe is the mind of God a black
hole Stephen Hawking gore Vidal Harold
Bloom and Wilson Dostoyevsky Einstein
and Madeleine can't see the name that's
it
all have their theories that's
Christopher Hitchens December of Vanity
Fair we have next caller on the air
Fairfax Virginia thank you very much uh
two things two points one I think mr.
Gargan is correct and saying there was a
double standard but it was a fluctuating
double standard on the bush person
Linton for example Bush's alleged affair
never got the you know Ted Koppel
exploiting the star magazine treatment
and all that lurid you know distortions
and prying and inflammation of the
non-issue but one thing I would
disrespectfully ask you mr. Gargan to
perhaps reassess it seems to me I've
listened to you several times you give
two benevolent and gentle and ambivalent
a spin on the whole Reagan Bush twelve
year legacy of a national debt four
trillion dollars quadrupling the Carter
national debt largely a byproduct of the
Reagan's Stockman laugher Kemp thesis of
trickle-down of lowering taxes
increasing the military and somehow
having this whole thing happened and
then the spin seems to be that there's a
distinction that the conservative
columnist are pointing out that Bush
didn't cue to this positive and valid
Reagan line of economic dynamism Reagan
basically was a disaster and if this
country can somehow can Seva Blee even
make the slightest dent in this horrific
deficit it's going to be a major miracle
and it seems to me because you were
involved in the Reagan administration
perhaps you're not as candid and I say
this is one who deeply admires you and
critical of this legacy which is largely
his doing he could have vetoed any bill
that Congress put out thank you sir
well let me let me responded I'd say the
question is well taken and I have said
on some forms not at all that I do view
the the debt and the deficits as a
terrible burden for this country and I
do believe as the Reagan team deserves a
good deal of the blame for it and I'm
part of I was part of that team early on
I think we made a serious error early on
and going for not going deep enough on
spending cuts we should have gone much
more aggressively after the federal
spending early on I also think we
probably went too deep on the tax cuts
although you if you recall what happened
back in 1981 the Congress added a lot of
additional tax cuts on to what the
President had proposed so I don't think
there's any question that the Reagan
Bush years there
bear a significant amount of
responsibility and blame for the
deficits I also think the Congress by
the way deserves some of the blame but I
I do think that there were some good
elements about the Reagan years and ones
and there's been an effort to trash the
Reagan years and in recent times that I
think goes too far some of those
deficits did go into a defense build-up
I happen to believe belong to the school
that the defense buildup of the 80s had
an ignition impact upon Soviet thinking
and that we won the Cold War in large
part because the United States played an
aggressive tough stand up kind of line
and that Ronald Reagan and George Bush
deserve credit for that and if we are
burdened with some deficits at least
we've got through a Cold War without a
lot of people being killed and we won
after all so I and when we yes yes
there's a mess in Soviet Union today but
it's one heck of a lot better mess from
our perspective than it would be if we
had a nation there poised with with
missiles and and and troops still very
close to a European border so I think
there was a lot of good things that
occurred there a lot of jobs were
created during that period of time there
was a lot of growth there is no question
that the deficits remain this the
biggest black mark and anybody who
thinks about that very has to say
by god we really blew that one Venice
California yes thank you very much for
c-span it's a really a remarkable amount
of illumination that we get from this
compared to what we saw during the
election in terms of media coverage I
just have two quick comments first I
think it's remarkable the way in which a
number of stories that had they been
perpetrated by one side or the other
received differential treatment in the
press for example the story of Jennifer
flowers was reduced to the question of
marital infidelity whereas in fact the
salient element the element that I think
should have been focused on was the fact
that her job was largely the creation of
some maneuvering on the part of Clinton
and bypassing an african-american woman
who would otherwise have been qualified
and from what I understand there was in
fact some sort of official agency
confirmation of her of her position and
so it seems that the press was able to
avoid an issue that had been perpetrated
by the member of the Bush administration
would have been you know
a national outcry and the Charlotte
Perry story had because it was in the
Clinton administration didn't appear in
the in the Clinton campaign and is his
administration as governor appeared to
be more or less buried alright what's
your other point sir I just wanted to
say about gays in the military that
while all the points about civil rights
and and the advancement of our society
as a whole are completely valid it seems
that the the overriding issue is the way
that in terms of morale is the way that
certain men would feel in the presence
of someone they now know to be a
homosexual and while those reactions may
be characterized as homophobic or
immature we have to understand they will
be there and I think that while people
focus on conduct I think that the
argument that if they conduct themselves
appropriately showering and so on and so
forth shouldn't be a problem that
argument would seem to also imply that
women and men should be able to shower
together that despite that as long as no
inappropriate conduct takes place I'll
listen for your answer
thanks very much on the gennifer flowers
story um what if she'd sued the
government for sexual harassment I
sometimes ask myself
she's a very old-fashioned type of girl
Jennifer flowers goodtime girl gets
wrong in the end anyone could have told
her she was going to get wrong
knows no better than go and blab to the
tabs and try and pick up a bit of money
but if it's true as I have been told it
is that she probably owed her job to the
favors she was doing than if she'd
charged sexual harassment I think we
would now be living in a very different
America me read to you James Carville on
Jennifer flowers this is from USA Today
this morning James Carville says the
person who elevated standards of this
campaigns election coverage was Jennifer
flowers Carville addressing the
Association Associated Press Managing
Editors convention in Honolulu on
Saturday suggested that flowers
unsubstantiated claims led news editors
to be more careful Carville compared
editors to quote a bunch of drunks who
get together after a campaign and you
talk and say we're not going to do this
again it's like detox then everybody
gets out of detox and Wow here comes Jen
for flowers and it was just like a
[ __ ] of whiskey everybody at the bar
and everybody's killing each other to
get at it all of a sudden everyone's got
a giant hangover and says I don't like
this and that accounted for better
coverage Wow
James is nothing if not colorful and he
remains so today and I what he calls a
fair coverage a lot of people
interpreted as more sympathetic coverage
and and it goes back to the point that
we've been trying to make here is it
once that episode ended I think the
press felt ashamed of itself to a degree
and and move back and laid off him and I
think did not question him it seriously
and I think it resulted more sympathetic
Kari quit can I go to this central point
because it sees me separately we are
going that we have had we've learned
white men had learned to sit down with
black men and we've made we've made a
lot of personal we've learned to sit
down with women at the table it's time
we learn we've got to sit down with
other people who are different than we
are we can share things and we in this
notion that you can't have a gay man in
the same shower we're not feeling
coverages think because we're gonna get
over that 20 seconds for Christopher
Hitchens what are you watching carefully
in this transition time can I pass him
just say was something about what David
got away with remember to go I mean
everybody was a loser in the Cold War in
my opinion and the United States has not
yet begun to pay the full price of the
war economy was noticeable during the
campaign that was a sign of Bush's
desperation but also a sign of the
persistence of the war economy in our
life was the attempt to buy votes by
keeping unnecessary military contracts
going there's something we haven't begun
to face yet but Webb faces as well as
long as we go around saying we won the
Cold War I think that the failure of the
Democrats also in that campaign to point
out that Bush was using the war economy
is a campaign to actually spoke volumes
about the political consensus and how
far we have to go our thanks to
Christopher Hitchens and David Gergen
for joining us for the past 90 minutes
and thanks to all of you for watching
and for your telephone calls have a good
week